though kim wexler starts off as a caring
but
very cautious girlfriend over the past
few seasons
we have seen her transform into a
boundary pushing adventure seeking
slipping kimmy
from standing up to lalo to having no
remorse and plotting to take down howard
kim
has shown that though she's fearful of
illegal as well as life-threatening
repercussions as she should be
her moral compass is really just as cute
as saul goodman
however unlike jimmy who turns to shady
legal practices due to constantly being
rejected by the traditional legal world
as well as his brother kim wexler turns
to dark side as she finds a bright side
unfulfilling
but during her time as a thriving lawyer
in the legal world
how much does sleeping kimmy make
well starting off with her financial
state we know that kim was more than
financially stable
as she was growing up kim was very poor
forcing her family to always rent and
flee temporary residences before
eviction
considering this unpleasant upbringing
it's no doubt that financial stability
is one of kim's top priorities as she
has had first-hand experience at
struggling to put a roof over her head
with this in mind kim moves from
nebraska to albuquerque
to pursue better career opportunities
and establish a more stable life for
herself
this pursuit leads her to working in the
mail room of hhm with jimmy
inspired by the various successful
lawyers within hhm
kim eventually pursues her own law
degree for which hhm pays for
given her hardcore work ethic she easily
worked her way to
law school and up the ladder of hhm
which is when we first hear him better
call saul
aside from scoring a nice paying job as
a lawyer
the show makes it clear that kim not
only makes good money
but she saves good money as well unlike
the average american
she's able to write a fifteen thousand
dollar check at a whim to howard for
paying for education
and offers to take care of jimmy's half
of the rent sleaze
when he's going through tough times but
how much does kim exactly make
well to estimate this we'll first take a
look at how long kim has been working at
hhm
at the start of better call saul kim is
about 34 years old
this is based on her birthday being
revealed in the episode jmm from season
as being february 13 1968
so at the start of better call saul kim
has about 16 years of adult life under
her belt
she likely got a bachelor's degree
before heading into the mail room
from a community college or a public
university using financial aid
as in the u.s most law schools require a
bachelor's degree
to pursue a law degree thus she likely
didn't enter the hhm mail room to a
minimum of 22 years old in season 1 of
better call saul
kim also reveals that she only has two
years left before becoming a partner at
the firm
considering that it takes five to seven
years to become a junior partner at a
law firm
kim had likely been a lawyer at hhm for
about four years at the start of better
call saul
meaning that she became a lawyer at 30
years old
however she ends up quitting by the end
of season 2
which leaves off just 6 months later
than where season 1 picked up
so assuming that she had no other jobs
in her adult life
kim's career with hhm consists of eight
years in the mail room
of which three years were also spent in
law school and four and a half years as
a lawyer
as for her time in the mail room the
median salary for mail clerks is 33
287 per year this was nearly 20 years
ago though
so we'll say that it was about 30 000
per year at the time
with eight years in the mail room this
would bring in 240
000 for kim as for her time as a lawyer
she was specifically a litigator for hhm
for which the median salary is 108
000 per year again docking up a bit
as this was 20 years ago kim was likely
making right about 100 000
a year as a litigator giving her 450 000
during her time at hhm adding this up
with her income from the mail room
kim made roughly 690 000 from hhm
accounting for any bonuses she likely
got time to time
kim likely made about seven hundred
thousand dollars with hhm
moving on to her time with mesa verde
the average hourly rate for an attorney
ranges between 100 and 400
kim's rate is likely in the 200 to 300
range
however considering the volume of work
makes at verdes giving kim
we'll assume they were able to get a
discount rate of 200
per hour lawyers are on average only
able to build 2.3 hours per day
however this is because the average
lawyer at a law firm
spends 33 percent of their time looking
for new clients and 48
of the time on business development mesa
verde
is kim's only major client and she's not
really on the lookout for new clients or
developing her business
on top of this mesa verde is
aggressively expanding
thus having plenty of work for kim to do
and she often even puts in overtime as
well
so she's likely able to charge a full
eight hours or even more per day
but will say she only builds six to keep
it conservative
at two hundred dollars per hour this
comes out to twelve hundred dollars per
day
or six thousand dollars per week and
twenty 24 thousand dollars per month
however this gig doesn't last very long
as she quickly joins up with schweikart
and cochlear in season four
she joins schweikert and coakley right
before the nine month flash forward in
season four
which forwards between march of 2003 and
january of 2004
this means that she joined schweikart in
coakley in about february of 2003
giving her six months to work with mesa
verde privately
during these six months kim would have
pulled in 144 thousand dollars from mesa
verde
at the start of this time period she
does have to pay for the wechsler mcgill
office
and near the end she has to pay for a
paralegal but
we'll just assume that she had a pair
legal the entire time
as that would more than account for both
of these costs
the median salary for a paralegal is 50
grand
but we'll assume kim pays 60 grand as
she has a high paying client
plus working with kim isn't the same as
working for a legal firm
as job security as well as additional
perks are basically non-existent
as a result hiring a paralegal for six
months would cost kim 30 grand
leaving her with 114 000 in profit
before going to schweighart and coakley
moving on to her time with schweighardt
and coakley
we know that kim creates a banking
division and becomes ahead
so essentially kim becomes a director of
the banking division of a large regional
firm
the median salary for such a position is
190 000
per year with perks but can go up past a
quarter million per year
now kim was already making well over 200
a year at 228 000 per year with their
private legal practice however
she likely had to take a pay cut to join
schweighardt and coakley
this is in return for more freedom and
less stress
as she can take on pro bono cases and
she doesn't have to worry about finding
new clients
as the firm will take care of that not
to mention the additional perks like her
audi
as a result after adjusting for the time
period it's likely
kim was making about 180 000 per year or
little over what the median was
at the time this job carries out to the
end of season 5
which ends in june of 2004 meaning that
kim held on to this job for about a year
and three months
during which she would have earned 225
adding up all of these together kim made
a little over one million dollars
throughout her career
at one million thirty nine thousand
dollars and knowing kim
she likely saved a significant portion
of this she probably saved ten percent
even when she was only making thirty
thousand dollars per year which likely
grew to 40
50 or 60 percent after she starts making
the big bucks
as she lives well below her means and
hasn't made any large purchases such as
a house
assuming she saves 10 during her mail
room days and 50
during her attorney days kim would have
a total of 418
500 in savings split between her
retirement accounts and her savings
accounts
and that's with no growth kim likely
takes advantage of 401ks and roth iras
so after sprinkling in a bit of growth
kim
roughly had half a million dollars in
total with forty to fifty thousand
dollars in a savings account for any
emergencies like peng howard
at this rate she could have easily
retired with upwards of ten million
dollars
however we know that kim doesn't slip
from money
she slips because she finds her work
unfulfilling
would you guys quit not fulfilling but
high paying job like kim
comment that down below also if you guys
like the depth of analysis then make
sure drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one